right i don't think this is going to be
like that for 20 years i have a question
no i have a rhetorical question for the
group here yeah this is an interesting
one so
there's no freebies in politics if you
do something you're getting rewarded or
you're going to pay a price people don't
do things for politicians out of the
goodness of their heart every single
radio and television ad for gavin newsom
for the last two months was tagged that
it was presented by reed hastings the
money that reed hastings spent
ran the media campaign for gavin newsom
and it was mentioned at the end of every
spot where they accused uh
larry elder of being right of trump
being an anti-vaxxer reed hastings reed
hastings re-hastings
does that come back now because of this
this this race the streaming wars does
he get an advantage most people know who
hastings is yeah i know he's the ceo of
netflix i don't think most people know
that he already has susan rice and
barack obama and michelle obama is bored
so i mean
look it is what it is here's here was
really honest to god looking at this my
biggest takeaway
san francisco runs the united states now
it's not new york it's not la it's not
even dc the whole united states runs
through silicon valley now and silicon
valley runs through san francisco
everything goes through san fran because
of the media social media
the politicians are are so in bed with
big tech and big tech is in san
francisco and you think about it you've
got gavin newsom dianne feinstein
barbara baxter you've got mala harris uh
nancy pelosi all of them san francisco
residents right and you're coming out
google facebook every tech company in in
america has their their hub their their
hub where now why does that scare me
because this is going to translate into
into general milly
who runs silicon valley
who who's running silicon valley right
now
do you think who has more say over what
google does
america dc or beijing
who dictates what facebook does today
dc or beijing
so
if silicon valley is now the power hub
the information center of america okay
and silicon valley doesn't answer to dc
and answers to beijing who's running the
information and unpack that why are you
saying that they all answer to beijing
you're saying all these big tech
companies are all answering to
absolutely ccp which which companies
they will change their
their their rules they will change what
they do which companies all of them if
you've been tracking this at all for
five years every single update that they
do every single thing that they do and
you're talking about hollywood we talk
about hollywood the southern part of the
state
john cena
are they
are they changing their movies to make
sure that they don't piss off
conservative americans or libertarian
americans or independent americans or
even democrats so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]